EC COMMITTEE IN THE
SENATE HAS COMMENCED. WE HAVE
OUR VICE CHAIR, SENATOR DALLI,
WHO IS HERE TODAY. SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH. AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH
THE FIRST ITEM ON THE AGENDA,
ITEM ONE AB 457 BY ASSEMBLY
MAJORITY LEADER AGUIAR-CURRY.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING. YEAH. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS, FIRST, I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL. IT'S TRULY
APPRECIATED, THIS IS A SIMPLE
BILL UNDER SB 1013. ALL WINE
BOXES, REGARDLESS OF SIZE, WERE
ASSIGNED A 25 CENT CRV OR BOTTLE
DEPOSIT ON SMALL BOXES THAT
RETAIL FOR A THAT, EXCUSE ME,
THAT RETAIL FOR A FEW DOLLARS
AND THAT ARE SOMETIMES SOLD IN
MULTI-PACKS. THAT 25 CENT
DEPOSIT ADDS UP QUICKLY. THESE
THESE PRODUCTS COMPETE WITH
CANNED PRODUCTS THAT ONLY HAVE A
FIVE CENT DEPOSIT. SO THE LARGER
THE DEPOSIT IS NOTICEABLE TO
CONSUMERS AND HURTS THE INDUSTRY
. THIS BILL CREATES MORE PARITY
ACROSS INDUSTRIES AND HELPS
CONSUMERS AND THE WINE INDUSTRY
TOO, BY LOWERING THE DEPOSIT FOR
SMALL BOXES OF WINE SPIRITS FROM
$0.25 TO $0.10, WHICH IS STILL
DOUBLE THE CRV REQUIRED FOR
COMPETING DRINKS. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
IS TIM SCHMELZER WITH THE WINE
INSTITUTE. OKAY. THANK YOU. AND
I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT
YOU WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE. YES, I WILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SO WE'VE GOT,
CURRENTLY IN SUPPORT EIGHT.
WE'VE GOT ONE OF YOUR WITNESSES,
MR. SCHMELZER. YEAH. TIM
SCHMELZER, REPRESENTING, WINE
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT AND, JUST
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS FOR
YOU. GREAT. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
, FOLKS WOULD LIKE TO COME UP IN
SUPPORT OF AB 457, PLEASE? THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
KURT KIMMEL, HIÂU. ON BEHALF OF
BEATBOX BEVERAGES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD
IN SUPPORT? OKAY. SEEING NONE,
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO COME
FORWARD IN OPPOSITION. ANY
WITNESSES? PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HI, MARK MURRAY WITH
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE AND
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT WITH
THOSE AMENDMENTS WE'RE REMOVING
OUR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. TO
THE STAFF, THE AUTHOR, THE
AUTHOR STAFF FOR PULLING THIS
TOGETHER. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ANY, ANYONE ELSE IN ROOM 1200
WHO WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD
IN OPPOSITION? OKAY. SEEING
NONE, SO WE'LL TAKE IT BACK HERE
TO THE DAIS. WE HAVE JUST ONE
OTHER MEMBER HERE, SO I DON'T
KNOW IF SENATOR MENTIONED LOVELY
AND PINK. OH, OKAY. NO QUESTIONS
RIGHT NOW. SO WE'LL LEAVE THIS
BILL ON CALL. BUT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR.
AYE. VOTE THIS IS A SIMPLE BILL.
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
PARTICULARLY YOUR STAFF. THEY
HAVE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
HELPING BRING THIS ALL TOGETHER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE'LL TAKE THAT AS
YOUR CLOSE AND WE'LL LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL BECAUSE WE DO NOT
HAVE, A QUORUM AT THIS TIME. SO
THANK YOU. I KNOW THE FEELING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE APPRECIATE THAT, MADAM
MAJORITY LEADER. ALL RIGHT. SO
NEXT WE WILL MOVE ON TO FILE.
AND ACTUALLY FILE ITEM TWO HAS
BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR. THAT IS
FILE ITEM TWO AB 627. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JACKSON. THEN WE'LL MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM FOUR, WHICH IS
AB 805 ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA.
WELCOME. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND SENATORS, FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT. I'LL
BEGIN BY APPRECIATING AND
THANKING YOUR STAFF FOR THE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK THAT'S
GONE INTO THIS BILL SINCE LAST
YEAR, AND I AM HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. THE
ASSEMBLY BILL 805 PROTECTS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES FROM
FAILING AND POORLY MANAGED
INFRASTRUCTURE BY AUTHORIZING
THE WATER BOARD TO REQUIRE A
SERVICE PROVIDER THAT HAS
DEMONSTRATED DIFFICULTY IN
MANAGING ITS SEWER SYSTEM TO
CONTRACT WITH AN OUTSIDE
ADMINISTRATOR DESIGNATED OR
APPROVED BY THE BOARD. IN
ADDITION, ASSEMBLY BILL 805
AUTHORIZES THE BOARD TO USE
FUNDS IN THE STATE WATER CLEANUP
AND ABATEMENT ACCOUNT AND THE
STATE WATER QUALITY CONTROL FUND
TO ISSUE GRANTS TO BE APPOINTED
ADMINISTRATORS TO COVER THEIR
COSTS. FAILING SANITATION
SYSTEMS CAN LEAK CONTAMINANTS
INTO UNDERGROUND AQUIFERS THAT
RESIDENTS RELY ON TO REPLENISH
THEIR WELLS. THESE CONTAMINANTS
CAN CAUSE ADVERSE HEALTH EFFECTS
SUCH AS GASTROINTESTINAL ILLNESS
, NERVOUS SYSTEM, OR
REPRODUCTIVE EFFECTS, AND
CHRONIC DISEASES SUCH AS CANCER.
THE WATER BOARD IS CURRENTLY
UNDERGOING A MULTI-YEAR
ASSESSMENT OF THE STATEWIDE NEED
FOR WASTEWATER UPGRADES. THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE THAT RESIDENTS
OF DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WON'T HAVE TO WAIT ANOTHER
DECADE TO GET SOME RELIEF IN
THIS PROCESS BEFORE THIS PROCESS
IS COMPLETED. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL 805 ARE
BERTHA DIAZ, A RESIDENT OF EAST
OROSI, AND KYLE JONES, WHO IS
THE POLICY AND LEGAL DIRECTOR AT
COMMUNITY WATER CENTERS. THANK
YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND BEFORE
WE GET TO YOUR WITNESSES, IF WE
CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM, PLEASE,
OKAY. SENATORS GONZALEZ HERE.
GONZALEZ HERE. DALI. HERE. DALI,
HERE. HURTADO LAIRD, HERE.
LAIRD, HERE. MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR.
HERE. NGUYEN SKINNER. OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, PLEASE GO
AHEAD, GOOD MORNING. KYLE JONES,
POLICY AND LEGAL DIRECTOR WITH
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER, JUST
REALLY WANT TO SHARE MOST OF OUR
TIME TO BERTHA DIAZ FOR THE
RESIDENT TO SHARE HER STORY WITH
TRANSLATION. BUT URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. AND I'M HERE FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS, SHOULD YOU
HAVE THEM. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
BERTHA DIAZ. SI VENGO DE LA
COMUNIDAD DE ESTE OROSI, YO
VENGO A ME TESTIMONIO DE TODAS
LAS INJUSTICIAS C¯ I IN NUESTRA
COMUNIDAD. TAMBIÉN. YOU WANT ME
TO TRANSLATE OR. OKAY. SORRY.
I'M HAPPY TO. HI, MY NAME IS
BERTHA DIAZ. I'M HERE FROM THE
COMMUNITY OF EAST OROSI IN
TULARE COUNTY, AND I'M HERE TO
GIVE MY TESTIMONY ON THE
INJUSTICES WE'VE BEEN FACING.
PARTICIPO EN LA IN VECINOS
UNIDOS. C¯ ES REPRESENTANDO A
NUESTRA COMUNIDAD DE ESTEROS E
TAMBIÉN ESTE SOY MIEMBRO DE LA
COALICION DEL AGUA POR DE CINCO
ANOS. SO I'M PART OF VECINOS
UNIDOS, WHICH REPRESENTS THE
COMMUNITY OF EAST OROSI AND ALSO
PART OF THE AGUA COALITION FOR
25 YEARS. SOLAMENTE LO
RESIDENTES QUÊ VIVIMOS EN LA
COMUNIDAD DE ESTE OROSI. SABEMOS
LÀ SITUACIÓN ES TAN DIFICILES
QUÊ VIVIMOS EN NUESTRA COMUNIDAD
. ONLY US, THE RESIDENTS OF EAST
OROSI, KNOW THE DIFFICULT
SITUATIONS WE'RE FACING HERE IN
OUR COMMUNITY. NOSOTROS TENEMOS
MUCHOS PROBLEMAS PUES
PRINCIPALMENTE EL AGUA ESTA ALTA
AND NITRATES ARE TAMBIÉN LA
AMPLIA. TENEMOS C¯ NO RECEIVE
LOS VILLAS ANOS MALTRATA AMENAZA
UNOS AL RESIDENT ES C¯ VAYA MÀ A
INMIGRACIÓN PARA DEPORTADOS
PORQUE SIEMPRE SIMPLEMENTE NOS
DEPENDEMOS NUESTROS DERECHOS. SO
WE FACE MULTIPLE PROBLEMS,
MAINLY THE WATER IS HIGH IN
NITRATES AS WELL AS THE EMPLOYEE
OF THE WATER PROVIDER THAT
PROVIDES OUR BILLS, THREATENS
US, AND THREATENS TO CALL
IMMIGRATION ON US WHEN WE JUST
DEMAND THE RIGHT TO SEE OUR
BILLS AND BE TREATED FAIRLY.
PORQUE LA MAYORIA DE LOS
RESIDENTES C¯ VIVIMOS EN ESA
COMUNIDAD, PUES ES GENTE HISPANA
GENTE C¯ TRABAJAR EN EL CAMPO DE
BAJO RECURSOS, A VECES LA AGUA,
MUCHOS DE LOS RESIDENTES
PRINCIPALMENTE A ME NO NOS
AJUSTA CINCO BOTELLAS DE AGUA
POR UN MES. THE MAJORITY OF THE
COMMUNITY THERE IN EAST OROSI IS
HISPANIC, AND OF, LOW INCOME.
AND A LOT OF TIMES THE ALLOTTED
FIVE WATERS, FIVE WATER BOTTLES,
THEY GET A MONTH JUST DOESN'T
LAST. TAMBIÉN A VECES SE NOS
TI¾N A LA LAS VOCES BECAUSE YO
DESDE C¯ COMPRA ME PROPIEDAD A
NOS DIJERON C¯ CADA ANO TENIAN
QUÊ LAS COSAS DÍAS NOSOTROS
VAMOS Y ABISMOS A LA AMPLIADA E
NØ ESTÁ ACCESSIBLE A UNA
EMERGENCIA. YO TUVE POR DOS
SEMANAS Y MEDIA IN ME HOGAR
LLENO DE AGUAS NEGRAS. AND
SOMETIMES THE SEPTIC TANKS
OVERFLOW, WE WERE TOLD. I WAS
TOLD WHEN I BOUGHT THE HOUSE
THAT THE SEPTIC TANK SHOULD BE
CLEARED OUT ANNUALLY AND, LAST
YEAR THERE WAS AN INCIDENT WHERE
MY HOUSE WAS FILLED WITH, WASTE
WATER FOR TWO WEEKS, TWO AND A
HALF WEEKS, AND THE EMPLOYEE OF
THE, THE WATER PROVIDER WAS NOT
HELPFUL. Â. YO SOY UNA UNA
MUJER QUÊ ME TOCO SER PADRE Y
MADRE DE MIS HIJOS. TENGO UNA
MUCHACHA QUÊ. AQUI ESTA PRESENTE
CONMIGO. MARIBEL SANCHEZ ELLA ES
UNA JOVEN DE CAPACITÉ DE QUÊ
ELLA NÓ VÆ Y CON NECESIDADES
ESPECIALES. YO PIENSO C¯
NOSOTROS MERECEMOS UN MEJOR
TRATO DE LA OFICINA DE DONDE
PAGAMOS LOS VILLAS Y QUÊ NO HAGA
VILLAS FRAUDULENTOS PORQUE ELLA
SIEMPRE DICEN QUÊ DEBEMOS MAS
CUANDO NO LO NO LO ES Y TAMBIÉN
NOS PIDE QUÊ NOSOTROS NO LOS
VILLAS YA HEMOS PAGADO PARA
PODER ELLA VER SI DEBEMOS Ó NO
ELLA NO TIENE NINGUNA NINGUNA
EXPEDIENTE DE NINGUN RESIDENTE.
GRACIAS POR SU TESTIMONIO. THANK
YOU. IF YOU WANT TO TRANSLATE,
PLEASE. YEAH. SO, SHE IS A
SINGLE MOTHER AND SHE'S BEEN
RAISING A DAUGHTER WITH
DISABILITIES. SHE'S BLIND AND
HAS SPECIAL NEEDS, AND, IT'S THE
UNFAIR TREATMENT FROM THE WATER
PROVIDER AND HOW THEY ARE BILLED
UNFAIRLY. THEY'RE PROVIDED WITH
FRAUDULENT BILLS AND, SHE'S JUST
ASKING THAT SHE HAS THE RIGHT TO
BE TREATED FAIRLY AND TO BE
BILLED PROPERLY. THANK YOU.
GRACIAS. THANK YOU. NO TENEMOS
MUCHO TIEMPO DESCULPE. PERO
VAMOS A SEGUIR CON LA PROXIMA
PERSONA. OKAY, WE'LL MOVE TO THE
NEXT PERSON. BUT I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER SUPPORT
WITNESSES. OKAY. ANY OTHER FOLKS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TODAY.
THAT IS AB 805. GOOD MORNING
MICHAEL CLAIBORNE WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND I WAS ALSO ASKED TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR CLEAN WATER
ACTION. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
ANGELA ISLAS WITH CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
NETWORK AND IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING, JACOB EVANS WITH
SIERRA CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. OKAY. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OKAY. SEEING NONE NOW
WE'LL MOVE TO OPPOSITION. ANYONE
WHO'D LIKE TO COME FORWARD. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF AB
805? GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
JESSICA GAGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES. I'M HAPPY
TO REPORT THAT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY, WE ARE
MOVING FROM AN OPPOSED POSITION
TO A NEUTRAL POSITION. JUST
REALLY WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR,
SPONSOR AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS. GOOD MORNING, JULIA
HALL WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES. WANT
TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
JESSICA GAGER FROM CASA. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, DON GILBERT.
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THE
AMENDMENTS AND WILL REMOVE OUR
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WELL,
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE WILL NOW
MOVE BACK TO THE DÍAS. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS? SENATOR LAIRD, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR, FOR DOING THIS,
BILL. AND I REALLY IT WAS GOING
TO BE MY QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER
THE OPPOSITION HAD BEEN REMOVED.
IT GETS ANSWERED IN THE
TESTIMONY, AND I AM DOING A
SIMILAR BILL THAT REQUIRES,
THERE TO BE BASICALLY THE TMF
TECHNICAL, MANAGERIAL AND
FINANCIAL FAILINGS ON SMALL
WATER AGENCIES BECAUSE WE HAVE
THE SAME ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ISSUES AND ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES
OF SMALL AGENCIES NOT HAVING THE
CAPACITY. TO DO IT. AND, AND
IT'S NICE TO GET IN FRONT OF
THAT AND FIGURE OUT, I MEAN, IN
THIS CASE, AND I'M NOT SURE IT
FALLS OVER TO SEWAGE. I MEAN,
WHEN THE FIRE HAPPENED IN THE
SANTA CRUZ MOUNTAINS, THE CCU
FIRE WAS ONE WATER DISTRICT WENT
SO BELLY UP AND THEY COULDN'T
EVEN TELL WHO THEIR CUSTOMERS
WERE, WHETHER THEY WERE ON
SERVICE, AND IT COST ALMOST $1
MILLION OF, OF PUBLIC MONEY TO
COME IN AND TRY TO UPRIGHT IT.
AND SO I THINK YOU Tê IN THE
SEWAGE SPHERE ARE TRYING TO GET
IN FRONT OF THIS AND EXACTLY THE
SAME WAY. AND THE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THAT IT'S NOT AS FAR
REACHING AS SOME OF THE
DISTRICTS WERE CONCERNED ABOUT,
BUT IT DOES REACH WHEREVER THERE
IS A FAILING AGENCY. SO, MADAM
CHAIR, I WOULD MOVE THE BILL.
GREAT. THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH,
SENATOR DALI, THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. FIRST OFF, I WANTED TO
SAY THAT THIS IS NOT UNIQUE TO
YOUR DISTRICT, THIS IS SOMETHING
I KNOW THAT THE SENATOR LAIRD
WAS JUST TALKING ABOUT, BUT. BUT
I WANT TO DRILL DOWN A LITTLE
BIT DEEPER BECAUSE, WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO FIGURE THIS OUT. AND
ACTUALLY, WHAT WE DO IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES, THE
WITNESS TALKED ABOUT SEPTICS. SO
THIS IS MORE FOCUSED TOWARDS,
SYSTEMS, WASTEWATER SYSTEMS, NOT
SEPTIC SYSTEMS. CORRECT? THAT'S
CORRECT. OKAY. I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT I GOT THAT RIGHT,
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT SEPTICS ARE
DIFFERENT THAN WASTEWATER
SYSTEMS, BUT AND I KNOW I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL, BUT
I WANT TO JUST MORALLY GET MAYBE
HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE'RE FACED WITH, NOT JUST
IN YOUR AREA, BUT ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA. YOU HAVE PROP 218
THAT DOESN'T ALLOW YOU TO
WITHOUT THE VOTE OF THE PEOPLE
TO RAISE THE RATES. NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, THE AND THEY'RE SO
THEY'RE SO THEY'RE SO I TALKED
TO THE WATER MANAGERS. MY FATHER
IN LAW ACTUALLY RUNS A COMMUNITY
SERVICE DISTRICT IN MY DISTRICT,
AND IS VERY FRUSTRATED WITH THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICE NUMBER ONE AND
UPGRADE A SYSTEM THAT IS 50
YEARS OLD AND IS LEAKING AND
NEEDS REPAIR AND CAN'T GET THE
RESOURCES FROM THE DISTRICT, THE
ABILITY TO RAISE THE RATE, TO
ACTUALLY DO THE JOB. AND AT THE
END OF THE DAY, WE HAVE
REVOLVING LOANS, ABILITY TO DO
THAT. THERE'S WE DO THE STATE
DOES PUT OUT A LOT OF RESOURCES,
BUT THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
SOMEBODY TO WRITE THE GRANT AND
THEN BE ABLE TO GET THE GRANT
AND THEN ADMINISTER IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT. SO I WANT TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY, BUT I WANT TO
SAY THAT, YOU KNOW, THERE'S A
BIGGER OVERARCHING PROBLEM HERE,
WE CAN RUN BILLS ALL DAY LONG,
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE
REALLY NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN ACTUALLY HELP THESE SMALL,
WATER PROVIDERS, GET THROUGH THE
PROCESS IN A WAY THAT WORKS. SO
I'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL,
BUT I JUST WANT TO BRING THAT TO
LIGHT, THAT THIS IS NOT UNIQUE
TO YOUR DISTRICT. IT'S
EVERYWHERE THAT THAT AND WE HAVE
SOME CHALLENGES WITH THE LAWS
THAT ARE IN PLACE TO BE ABLE TO
UP THE RATES ENOUGH TO PAY FOR
THE WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DALY. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS? OKAY SEEING
NONE. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. I AGAIN JUST WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS
A TWO YEAR BILL, AND WE SLOWED
DOWN TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GOT
THE BILL DONE CORRECTLY. YOU
SEE, THROUGH THE PROCESS THAT
WE'VE REMOVED THE OPPOSITION AND
THAT'S COME THROUGH THE HARD
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF. AND
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY
KNOW MY APPRECIATION AS WE'RE
ABLE TO MORE URGENTLY ADDRESS
THE WASTEWATER NEEDS UP AND DOWN
OUR STATE. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU AND GREAT WORK.
SO WE'VE GOT A MOTION BY SENATOR
LAIRD, AND THAT IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE, MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
DALLI AYE. DALLI. AYE. HURTADO.
LAIRD LAIRD. AYE. MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. NO AYE. MENGIBAR I
SORRY. NGUYEN. SO WE'VE DONE
NUMBER ONE. SKINNER THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. WE'LL LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ALL RIGHT. NEXT
WE'LL MOVE TO OUR FILE ITEM FIVE
AB 990. I C ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON IN THE CROWD. THERE HE
IS. WELCOME.
HI. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL. AB
990 WOULD REQUIRE THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA REGIONAL
WATER QUALITY CONTROL BOARD TO
REVISIT A PART OF THEIR
MUNICIPAL REGIONAL STORMWATER
PERMIT THAT THREATENS THE
PROGRESS THAT HAS BEEN MADE TO
HELP STREAMLINE THE CONSTRUCTION
OF INFILL HOUSING TO DEAL WITH
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS,
NUMEROUS POLICIES HAVE BEEN
ENACTED TO HELP REDUCE THE
BARRIERS TO HOUSING DEVELOPMENT,
BUT THE RECENT ACTIONS OF THE
BAY AREA REGIONAL WATER QUALITY
BOARD THREATENED TO THE PROGRESS
THAT HAS BEEN MADE ALREADY UNDER
THE MOST RECENT CHANGES THAT
WERE ADOPTED LAST YEAR BY THE
BOARD TO THE MUNICIPAL REGIONAL
STORMWATER PERMITS, THE BOARD
HAS IMPOSED VERY STRINGENT
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
REQUIREMENTS AND HAS REQUIRED
THE USE OF LOW IMPACT
DEVELOPMENT TECHNIQUES IN ORDER
FOR DEVELOPMENTS TO QUALIFY FOR
THE BOARD'S MINIMUM CREDIT. THIS
WOULD HAVE A REALLY A
DETRIMENTAL IMPACT ON SEVERAL
DEVELOPMENTS ACROSS THE BAY AREA
THAT ARE ALREADY IN THE
PIPELINE. SO TO AVOID THESE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS, AB 990 WOULD
REQUIRE THE REGIONAL WATER
QUALITY BOARD TO REVISIT THE
SPECIAL CATEGORY C PERMITS THAT
HAVE AN EFFECT ON AFFORDABLE
INFILL HOUSING AND CONSULT WITH
REGIONAL AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
SUCH AS ABAG AND MTC. COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS, BUSINESS GROUPS
AND HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO MAKE
SURE THAT AN THAT AN UPDATED
PERMIT WILL NOT IMPAIR
DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING IN THE
BAY AREA, SO THE BILL DOES NOT
AFFECT PARTS OF THE PERMIT THAT
ARE RELATED TO STORMWATER
POLLUTION MANAGEMENT, BUT IS
NARROWLY TAILORED TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND THROUGH THE CHAIR. I DO HAVE
A WITNESS TODAY FROM THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL, LUIS MORANTE.
THANK YOU. WELCOME GOOD MORNING,
MADAM. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
MY NAME IS LUIS MORANTE. I
REPRESENT THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
ON ISSUES RELATED TO HOUSING,
AND I'VE WORKED ON THIS PERMIT
FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS, I
THINK, MR. GRAYSON. ABSOLUTELY
NAILS THE ISSUE HERE. AND I JUST
WANTED TO ADD THAT THE COUNCIL,
WHILE WE REPRESENT DEVELOPERS,
WORKS TO MAKE THE BAY AREA THE
BEST PLACE TO LIVE AND WORK, AND
THAT INCLUDES PROTECTING THE BAY
AREA'S ENVIRONMENT, WHICH THIS
PERMIT GENERALLY DOES, IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT WE'RE NOT
STREAM LINING INFILL HOUSING IN
THE WAY THAT WE USED TO UNDER
VERSION TWO OF THE PERMIT,
BECAUSE THAT NOT JUST HARMS OUR
HOUSING MARKET, BUT ALSO HARMS
OUR ABILITY TO PROTECT OUR
ENVIRONMENT BY ENCOURAGING
SPRAWL AND DISCOURAGING INFILL.
I STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL AND AM HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS, BECAUSE
IT CAN GET PRETTY TECHNICAL
PRETTY FAST THAT YOU HAVE ABOUT
THIS ISSUE OR ABOUT OUR
INVOLVEMENT IN THIS PERMIT IN
THE LAST THREE YEARS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? YES MADAM
CHAIR, MEMBERS SILVIO FERRARO,
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT. STEPHEN
SPENCER WITH BROWN STEIN ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO COME FORWARD IN ROOM
1200? OKAY. SEEING Þ, WE MAY
HAVE ONE MORE. OH ALL RIGHT, NOW
WE'LL MOVE TO OPPOSITION. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? PLEASE
COME FORWARD. OKAY. ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. ALL
RIGHT, WE'LL TAKE IT BACK TO THE
DAIS FOR ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM SENATORS. I MOVE
THE BILL. OKAY. JUST HAVE A
QUICK QUESTION. I KNOW, CAN YOU
JUST PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION AS
TO WHY THIS IS A SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE? I KNOW IT'S BEEN
OUTLINED, BUT, AND WHAT
PROTECTIONS THERE MIGHT BE TO
PREVENT A FUTURE PARTY FROM
DOING THE SAME THING WITH
ANOTHER PERMIT IN THE FUTURE. SO
I THINK IF I READ, READ INTO
THAT SOMEWHAT OF A PRECEDENT.
AND IF WE WANT TO TALK PRECEDENT
, FIRST OF ALL, FACING A
PRECEDENT OR SETTING A PRECEDENT
IS REALLY NOT TO BE TAKEN
LIGHTLY. AND SO WITH THIS, I
THINK THE REAL QUESTION IS, DOES
THE, IS THIS PARTICULAR AGENCY
THE APPROPRIATE AGENCY TO
ACTUALLY START SETTING
GUIDELINES AND POLICIES FOR
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT, OR, OR IS
IT BETTER, BETTER MET THROUGH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND THROUGH
LOCAL AGENCIES AS WELL AS
DEVELOPERS, THAT ARE THERE. SO I
THINK THE PURPOSE OF AB 990 IS
TO REALLY CREATE THOSE LANES AND
HELP EVERYBODY WORK TOGETHER,
RATHER THAN SILO THEMSELVES INTO
WHERE THEY ACTUALLY COME, END UP
IN CONFLICT. SO WITH THAT, I
AGAIN, CAN GET TECHNICAL, BUT IF
YOU WANT SOMETHING A LITTLE MORE
IN DEPTH, WE'RE GOOD. OKAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE I
ADDRESSED THAT QUESTION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY. HAVE A
MOTION. I BELIEVE BY SENATOR
DALLI. DID YOU WANT TO CLOSE AS
WELL? RESPECTFULLY. OKAY. WE'LL
TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOSE,
ACTUALLY. ALL RIGHT, SENATOR
DOLLY'S MOTION AND THIS IS A DUE
PASS TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE, MADAM SECRETARY, CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATOR
GONZALEZ? AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
DOLLY. DOLLY. AYE HURTADO.
LAIRD. AYE. LAIRD AYE. MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. AYE NGUYEN. SKINNER.
ALL RIGHT. WE'LL LEAVE THE BILL
ON CALL FOR NOW. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. IS IT
APPROPRIATE TO MOVE THE CONSENT
AGENDA? ABSOLUTELY. WE'VE GOT
SEVEN ITEMS ON CONSENT. SO, JUST
FOR CLARITY, FILE ITEMS THREE,
TEN, 11, 12, 13, 14 AND 15, ALL
ON CONSENT. AND I WOULD MOVE
THOSE ITEMS. I ASSUMED YOU
WOULD. THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD.
SO SENATOR LAIRD MOVES THE
CONSENT CALENDAR, MAY WE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL? SENATORS?
GONZALEZ. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
DALLI DALLI. AYE. HURTADO. LAIRD
AYE. LAIRD. AYE MÀ. AYE. NGUYEN.
SKINNER THANK YOU. OKAY. NOW
WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
SEVEN. I C ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
IN THE CROWD. THAT IS AB 2503.
WELCOME. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, TODAY I AM
PRESENTING AB 2503. FIRST, I
WANT TO SAY THAT I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS REFERENCED
ON PAGE SIX OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. AND I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS BILL. AB 2503
WILL STREAMLINE DELIVERY OF
TRAIN ELECTRIFICATION PROJECTS.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FACES
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS IN MEETING
ITS CLIMATE GOALS. ACCORDING TO
THE ARB'S 2022 SCOPING PLAN,
VMT, OR VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
REDUCTIONS WILL PLAY AN
INDISPENSABLE ROLE IN REDUCING
OVERALL TRANSPORTATION ENERGY
DEMAND AND ACHIEVING THE STATE'S
CLIMATE, AIR QUALITY AND EQUITY
GOALS. THE REPORT ALSO
EMPHASIZES THAT A KEY STRATEGY
TO ACHIEVE VMT REDUCTIONS
REQUIRE THE STATE TO INVEST IN
MAKING PUBLIC TRANSIT A VIABLE
ALTERNATIVE TO DRIVING BY
INCREASING AFFORDABILITY,
RELIABILITY, COVERAGE, SERVICE
FREQUENCY, AND CONSUMER
EXPERIENCE. ELECTRIFICATION OF
LOCOMOTIVES WILL BE AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THE LARGER STRATEGY TO
REDUCE TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS,
AND EXISTS AS THE NEXUS OF AIR
QUALITY AND CLIMATE GOALS.
ELECTRIFIED TRAINS ARE FASTER
AND WOULD ALLOW TRANSIT AGENCIES
TO RUN TRAINS MORE FREQUENTLY.
IN ADDITION, THE ELECTRIFICATION
OF EXISTING RAIL CORRIDORS WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE SOURCES OF
AIR POLLUTION THAT ACUTELY
AFFECTS FRONT LINE COMMUNITIES
WITH POLLUTANTS SUCH AS NITRIC
OXIDE, OZONE, AND OTHER
PARTICULATE MATTER. AT A TIME
WHEN WE NEED ELECTRIFY OUR RAIL
LINES HAS NEVER BEEN MORE CLEAR.
SUBSTANTIAL BARRIERS REMAIN TO
DELIVER PROJECTS IN A TIMELY
FASHION. AS AN EXAMPLE, CALTRANS
LONG AWAITED RAIL
ELECTRIFICATION PROJECT WAS
DELAYED FOR YEARS, IN PART DUE
TO LEGISLATION THÀNH AB 2503,
WHICH ALLOWED THE STATE TO SCALE
UP DECARBONIZATION OF ITS
TRANSIT SYSTEM AND REDUCE THE
COST OF ELECTRIC. OUR RAIL
SYSTEM, AND WITHOUT INTRODUCING
INTRODUCE MY LEAD WITNESS IN
SUPPORT MARK VUCEKOVICH FOR
STREETS FOR ALL. THANK YOU.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE. MARK SHEETS FOR ALL
OUR BILLS. INTENT IS FAIRLY
SIMPLE. IT'S EXEMPTING RAIL
CORRIDORS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
SERVED BY DIRTY DIESEL
LOCOMOTIVES FROM ELECTRIFYING
FROM SEQUA. THIS WOULD EXEMPTION
WOULD PROHIBIT LENGTHY AND OFTEN
PROHIBITIVE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
AND REALLY IMPORTANTLY THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR BAD FAITH
LITIGATION. DIESEL TRAINS HAVE
PLAYED A REALLY IMPORTANT ROLE
IN OUR TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM,
AND WE SUPPORT THEIR CONTINUED
USE. WE'RE BIG TRAIN SUPPORTERS,
BUT COMMUNITIES LIVING NEAR
DIESEL RAIL CORRIDORS ARE OFTEN
EXPOSED TO HIGHER LEVELS OF AIR
POLLUTANTS, WHICH LEAD TO
RESPIRATORY DISEASES,
CARDIOVASCULAR ISSUES, OTHER
HEALTH PROBLEMS. ELECTRIFYING
THESE CORRIDORS IS A DIRECT
ACTION TOWARDS THESE MITIGATING
THESE HEALTH RISKS,
ELECTRIFICATION ISN'T NOVEL OR
NEW. IT'S NOT AS NEW AS EVS.
ELECTRIFIED TRAINS HAVE BEEN
RUNNING FOR THE PAST 100 YEARS.
ONE OF THE MOST BEST EXAMPLES,
ACTUALLY, ONE THAT WAS RUNNING
IN SACRAMENTO FOR QUITE A LONG
TIME, AND MOST RECENTLY, YOU
THINK ABOUT CALIFORNIA HIGH
SPEED RAIL. YOU THINK ABOUT,
CALTRAIN. ALL OF THESE ARE
ELECTRIFIED RAIL CORRIDORS ARE
GOING TO BE AT LEAST ELECTRIFIED
RAIL CORRIDORS. YEAH. THIS
POLICY WILL HAVE FAR REACHING
BENEFITS, POTENTIALLY FOR
CALIFORNIA'S AMTRAK METROLINK
COASTER SERVICES, THE LOW SAND
CORRIDOR FOR THOSE PAYING
ATTENTION TO LOW SAND, CAPITAL
CORRIDOR TRACKS STAND TO GAIN
SUBSTANTIALLY FROM
ELECTRIFICATION FROM THE
RELIABILITY, EFFICIENCY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS, AND SO
IN LIGHT OF ALL THESE
CONSIDERATIONS, IN LIGHT OF THE
LITIGATION SAGA THAT ATHERTON
FACED WITH CALTRAIN
ELECTRIFICATION, YEAH. ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON, FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. SO WE'LL
INVITE ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO COME FORWARD IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. PLEASE MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, MICHAEL PIMENTEL
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION, VOICING OUR
SUPPORT ALSO ON BEHALF OF
CALTRAIN, ONE OF THE FEW
CORRIDORS THAT HAS ACTUALLY
ELECTRIFIED HERE IN SUPPORT.
ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. OKAY ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD IN
ROOM 1200? SEEING NONE WILL MOVE
ON TO OPPOSITION IF THERE IS ANY
SEEING NONE, WE'LL TAKE IT BACK
TO SENATORS MEMBERS. ANY
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS SENATOR
DALLI, SENATOR MEMBER I LOOKED
OVER YOUR BILL REALLY CLOSELY
AND I HAD ACTUALLY REACHED OUT
TO THE STAFF AND ASKED ABOUT,
CEQA EXEMPTIONS FOR THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AND SO THIS BILL IS
REALLY NOT TIGHT WHEN IT COMES
TO THE DEFINITIONS OF YES, WE'RE
I'M ALL FOR ELECTRIFYING, BUT I
DON'T WANT TO ALLOW A SECRET
EXEMPTION FOR THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL. AND THERE THERE MAY BE,
POSSIBILITIES WHERE WE STILL
HAVE, DIESEL ENGINES ON THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL THAT, WOULD BE ABLE
TO HAVE A SECRET EXEMPTION. SO
COULD YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT. I'M NOT GOING TO. I'M THE
WAY IT'S WRITTEN TODAY. I'D LOVE
TO SEE AN AMENDMENT THAT SAYS,
HEY, THIS DOES NOT INCLUDE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AT ALL. IS THAT
SOMETHING YOU'D BE WILLING TO
LOOK AT? SO THE BILL TODAY IS
ABOUT THE ELECTRICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES, RIGHT.
SO ON EXISTING RIGHT OF WAYS. SO
WHATEVER PATH IT IS ON A
PASSENGER RAIL, IT'S ABOUT THE
EXISTING RIGHT OF WAY. SO IF THE
RIGHT OF WAY DOESN'T EXIST YET
FOR A LINE OR SOMETHING, IT
WOULDN'T OBVIOUSLY YET APPLY TO
THAT. BUT IT'S FOR EXISTING
RIGHT OF WAYS. BUT YOU STILL
HAVE TO DO A CEQA EVEN IF THERE
PUTTING HIGH SPEED IN WHERE
THERE WAS AN EXISTING RAIL,
THERE STILL HAS TO BE. BUT THIS
WOULD BE FOR THE ELECTRICAL
SUPPORT ASPECT OF IT, NOT FOR
THE ACTUAL THE PART OF THE
LAYING OF THE RAILS ITSELF. SO
IF I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
RIGHT. SO IF CAPITAL CORRIDOR,
AN EXISTING RAIL CORRIDOR THAT
IS OF COURSE NOT ELECTRIFIED,
THIS IS ABOUT CEQA FOR THE
UPGRADES YOU DO TO MAKE ELECTRIC
, NOT NECESSARILY TO GO LAY THE
TRACK AND DO ALL THE OTHER
THINGS OF IT JUST TO DO THE
UPGRADING ASPECT OF IT, IF THAT
MAKES SENSE. SO, INCLUDING
CONSTRUCTION OR REHABILITATION
OF STATIONS, TERMINALS,
EXISTING, EXISTING OPERATION AND
FACILITIES. THAT'S THE PART I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT. THAT'S MORE
THAN ELECTRIFICATION. I'M BEING
TOLD IT'S ONLY APPLIES TO LEAD
LOCAL AGENCIES. SO IT WOULDN'T
APPLY TO HSR. ARE YOU WILLING TO
PUT THAT IN YOUR BILL, WE CAN
DEFINITELY DISCUSS MORE OF IT. I
THINK THE WAY IT'S WRITTEN TODAY
IS WARRANTED, BUT I'M HAPPY TO
HAVE FURTHER DISCUSSION WITH
YOU, SENATOR AND SENATOR. WE
WILL SEE THIS AGAIN IN
TRANSPORTATION. YES YES, AND I'M
ON THAT. YEAH, I AM TOO. SO
THANK YOU. SO WE'LL GET MORE
CLARITY WHEN WE GET TO SECOND
COMMITTEE FOR YOU TO. YES. AND
THANK YOU. I'M GLAD, YOU'LL BE
ENGAGING WITH THAT CLARITY. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS? ALL RIGHT, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE,
FOR THE FUTURE OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION, OUR ENVIRONMENT?
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. I WILL TAKE
SENATOR GUEVARA'S MOTIONING. I
SEE THAT OVER THERE. OKAY.
SENATOR MENDOZA IS MOTIONED. AND
THIS IS A Dð PASS, AS AMENDED TO
SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE,
WITH SENATOR MENDOZA MOTIONING,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS
GONZALEZ. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
DALLI HURTADO. LAIRD LAIRD. AYE.
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE. NGUYEN.
SKINNER. OKAY. WE'LL LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU, NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM EIGHT, WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN. I SEE
HER THERE. THANK YOU. WELCOME.
THAT THIS IS AB 2513. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB 2513. FIRST OFF, I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL, AND WE WILL BE TAKING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS IN ORDER TO
PREVENT EXCESSIVE EXPOSURE TO
NITROGEN DIOXIDE, CARBON
MONOXIDE, BENZENE AND OTHER
CARCINOGENIC BYPRODUCTS THAT
CAUSE HARMFUL HEALTH EFFECTS. AB
2513 WILL WILL REQUIRE CONSUMER
WARNING LABELS FOR ALL NEW GAS
STOVES SOLD IN CALIFORNIA. THE
LABELS WILL INFORM CONSUMERS OF
THE HAZARDS ASSOCIATED WITH GAS
STOVES AND OVEN APPLIANCES. THE
INFORMATION ON THE LABEL WILL BE
TAKEN DIRECTLY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
WEBSITE. PER COMENZÓ COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. THIS WILL ALLOW FOR
INCREASED VIGILANCE IN
INSTALLING AND PROPER USE OF GAS
STOVES IN ORDER TO PREVENT UNDUE
EXPOSURE. SIMILARLY, BY MAKING
THIS INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO
CONSUMERS AT THE POINT OF SALE,
IT WILL HELP THE PURCHASER MAKE
MORE INFORMED DECISIONS. AB 2513
WOULD REQUIRE THAT THE LABEL
WILL INSTRUCT ON PROPER
VENTILATION INSTALLATION TO
ALLOW FOR EXHAUST OF ALL HARMFUL
GASES. UNDERSTANDING OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF VENTING THE FUMES
THAT INITIALLY LEADS TO THIS
HAZARD. JUST RUNNING A STOVE FOR
MERE MINUTES WITH POOR
VENTILATION CAN LEAD TO INDOOR
CONCENTRATIONS OF NITROGEN
DIOXIDE THAT EXCEED THE EPA'S
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS FOR
OUTDOORS. THE AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION, THE ASSOCIATION,
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC HEALTH
ASSOCIATION, PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY, AND THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION HAVE
ALL SPOKEN OUT ABOUT GAS STOVE
POLLUTION. DESPITE THE GROWING
BODY OF EVIDENCE ABOUT THE
HEALTH RISKS OF GAS STOVES. MOST
OF THIS ISN'T COMMON KNOWLEDGE.
WHEN YOU GO TO THE STORE TO
PURCHASE A GAS STOVE, THERE'S
LITTLE TO SUGGEST THE EXTENT OF
THE HEALTH ISSUES INVOLVED WITH
APPLIANCES OR THE SAFETY
MEASURES, SUCH AS USING A VENT
HOOD THAT USERS THAT THE USERS
SHOULD TAKE AND WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY IS DOCTOR LISA
RASMUSSEN, A PEDIATRICIAN. THÀNH
AND CHEN ENGSTROM WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC INTEREST
NETWORK. CALPIRG. THANK YOU.
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS CHEN ENGSTROM. I'M THE
STATE DIRECTOR FOR CALPIRG, A
CONSUMER ADVOCACY GROUP IN
CALIFORNIA, AND WE ARE PROUD TO
SPONSOR AB 2513, WHICH WILL GIVE
CONSUMERS IMPORTANT INFORMATION
ABOUT THE HARMFUL POLLUTANTS
EMITTED FROM GAS STOVES. SO MORE
THAN FOUR DECADES OF RESEARCH
SHOW THAT GAS STOVES ARE
PRODUCING DANGEROUS LEVELS OF
INDOOR AIR QUALITY POLLUTION.
GAS STOVES CAN EMIT HARMFUL
LEVELS OF NITROGEN DIOXIDE,
CARBON MONOXIDE, METHANE,
FORMALDEHYDE AND BENZENE AND
JUST RUNNING A STOVE FOR MERE
MINUTES WITH POOR VENTILATION
CAN LEAD TO INDOOR
CONCENTRATIONS OF NITROGEN
DIOXIDE THAT EXCEED THE EPA'S
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS FOR
OUTDOORS BREATHING. THIS
POLLUTANT CAN EXACERBATE
PREEXISTING RESPIRATORY
ILLNESSES AND INCREASE THE RISK
OF ASTHMA SYMPTOMS, ESPECIALLY
FOR CHILDREN. A RECENT STANFORD
STUDY ALSO FOUND THAT GAS STOVES
CAN EMIT CARCINOGENIC BENZENE
LEVELS ABOVE THOSE FOUND IN
SECONDHAND SMOKE, INCREASING THE
RISK OF LEUKEMIA. DESPITE THE
GROWING BODY OF EVIDENCE ABOUT
THE HEALTH RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH
GAS STOVE POLLUTION, LACK OF
EDUCATION AND REGULATIONS LEAVE
CONSUMERS LARGELY UNAWARE OF
THESE RISKS AND WE FOUND THAT
STORE RETAILERS ARE NOT
PROVIDING THIS INFORMATION TO
CONSUMERS, WAS IN FEBRUARY, US
EDUCATION FUND RELEASED THE
RESULTS OF A CONSUMER SURVEY
THAT FOUND THREE QUARTERS OF
SURVEY TAKERS WERE TOLD BY
WORKERS IN MAJOR RETAILERS THAT
GAS STOVE POLLUTION WAS NOT A
CONCERN, AND 8 IN 10 WERE TOLD
THAT VENTILATION WAS NOT
NECESSARY TO PROTECT HEALTH.
CONSUMERS DESERVE THE TRUTH WHEN
IT COMES TO THE HARMS OF GAS
STOVE POLLUTION, AB 2005 13 WILL
PROVIDE CONSUMERS WITH THIS
IMPORTANT INFORMATION SO THEY
CAN MAKE EDUCATED PURCHASING
DECISIONS AS WELL AS INFORMATION
ON PROPER VENTILATION IF THEY
CHOOSE TO PURCHASE A GAS STOVE,
A GAS STOVE WARNING LABELS ARE A
SIMPLE STEP THAT CALIFORNIA CAN
TAKE TO EMPOWER FAMILIES TO MAKE
GOOD DECISIONS FOR THEIR HEALTH.
WE THANK YOU AND ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME THANK YOU. CHAIR
GONZALEZ AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU TODAY IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL 2513. MY NAME IS DOCTOR
LISA RASMUSSEN. I'M A
PEDIATRICIAN AND I FULLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AS A PEDIATRICIAN,
DEEPLY INVESTED IN THE HEALTH
AND WELL-BEING OF OUR CHILDREN,
I FEEL THAT IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
WE MAKE POTENTIAL HEALTH RISKS
CLEAR TO OUR FAMILIES. THE
EVIDENCE IS CLEAR GAS STOVES
POSE A SIGNIFICANT HEALTH RISK.
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
EMISSIONS FROM INDOOR GAS STOVES
PRODUCE NITROGEN DIOXIDE, CARBON
MONOXIDE AND BENZENE, AND ALL OF
THESE CAN HAVE DETRIMENTAL
IMPACTS ON OUR HEALTH. NITROGEN
DIOXIDE HAS BEEN FOUND TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED RISKS OF ASTHMA,
DECREASED BRAIN FUNCTION, HEART
DISEASE, AND STROKE. CHILDREN
ARE MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE
IMPACTS OF INDOOR AIR POLLUTION.
CHILDREN LIVING IN A HOME WITH A
GAS STOVE HAVE A 42% INCREASED
RISK OF EXPERIENCING ASTHMA
SYMPTOMS IN CALIFORNIA, 20% OF
CHILDHOOD ASTHMA CASES ARE
ATTRIBUTED TO POLLUTANTS
ASSOCIATED WITH GAS STOVE USAGE.
FOR CHILDREN WITH ASTHMA, THESE
INDOOR POLLUTANTS ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH WORSE RESPIRATORY SYMPTOMS
AND INCREASED MEDICATION USAGE.
CHILDREN LIVING IN APARTMENTS
AND SMALLER SPACES ARE AT A
HIGHER RISK DUE TO HIGHER
NITROGEN DIOXIDE LEVELS, PUTTING
OUR UNDERSERVED FAMILIES AT A
HIGHER RISK, MAKING IT EVEN MORE
IMPERATIVE THAT WE TAKE ACTION.
AS A PARENT MYSELF, WE SWITCHED
FROM A GAS TO ELECTRIC STOVE TO
MINIMIZE INDOOR POLLUTANTS AND
PROTECT OUR CHILD'S HEALTH. IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT OTHER PARENTS
ARE MADE AWARE OF THESE RISKS SO
THAT THEY CAN MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS BY REQUIRING CLEAR
LABELING OF GAS STOVES AS A
POTENTIAL HEALTH HAZARD, WE CAN
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING OF OUR CHILDREN AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS. SO IN
CLOSING, I URGE YOU TO STAND UP
FOR THE HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITY
BY SUPPORTING AB 2513. THANK YOU
FOR SUPPORTING THE HEALTH OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU DOCTOR.
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS, NOW
WE'LL WELCOME ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. AB
2513, PLEASE. CHAIR MEMBERS
ALICIA PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF SAN
JOSE CLEAN ENERGY AND STRONG
SUPPORT, PRISCILLA. KUDOS HERE
ON BEHALF OF STOPWASTE IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, JACOB
EVANS WITH THEORETICAL
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING, MARK
FENSTERMAKER, ON BEHALF OF
PENINSULA CLEAN ENERGY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
WHO'D LIKE TO COME FORWARD IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL? SEEING
NONE, WE'LL TURN IT OVER TO
OPPOSITION. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF AB 2513, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING. COMMITTEE. GOOD
MORNING. ASSEMBLYWOMAN I'M KEVIN
MESNER. I'M WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF HOME APPLIANCE MANUFACTURERS,
YOU KNOW, I GOT UP THIS MORNING
AND WE USED A LOT OF APPLIANCES
EVERY DAY. WE TRUST THEM. AND I
NOTICED IN THE BATHROOM IT
WASN'T COMPLETELY PUT AWAY. WE
HAD A HAIR DRYER ON THAT HAIR
DRYER. THERE WAS A BIG WARNING
LABEL SAID RISK TO CHILDREN OF
DEATH TO ELECTRIC SHOCK AND A
PICTURE OF A BATHTUB. AND DON'T
PUT IT IN WATER. THESE WARNINGS
ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO PEOPLE'S
LIVES. EVERY DAY. COOKING THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY,
UNATTENDED COOKING IS A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE THAT PEOPLE
NEED TO BE AWARE OF. EDELMAN.
EDELMAN DOES A TRUST BAROMETER
EVERY YEAR. THIS YEAR, THEY
FOUND THAT 66% OF PEOPLE FEEL
THAT GOVERNMENT IS MISLEADING
THEM. THEY TRUST THEIR TRUSTED
SOURCE OF INFORMATION, ARE
SOMEONE LIKE ME. THAT'S EQUAL TO
A SCIENTIST. THEY GET THEIR
INFORMATION FROM ONLINE RESEARCH
OR SOCIAL MEDIA. THE GOOD NEWS
ON THIS IS THE CREDIBLE SOURCE
OF INFORMATION IS MOST CREDIBLE.
WHEN BUSINESS AND GOVERNMENT
AGREE ON INFORMATION THAT'S TRUE
AND ACCURATE AND CREDIBLE, THEN
PEOPLE WILL PAY ATTENTION TO
THIS. THE LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL,
EVEN WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, IS INACCURATE. IT'S
NOT CONSISTENT WITH WHAT CARB
HAS ON THEIR PUBLIC MESSAGING.
IT'S NOT CONSISTENT WITH CEC.
IT'S NOT CONSISTENT WITH EPA.
IT'S NOT CONSISTENT WITH
CONSUMER PRODUCT SAFETY
COMMISSION. IT'S NOT CONSISTENT
WITH ANY UNBIASED PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS IN THE US OR CANADA.
THAT IS GOING TO LEAD TO PEOPLE
DIMINISHING THE WARNING LABELS
EFFECTIVENESS, NOT ONLY FOR THIS
WARNING, BUT OTHER IMPORTANT
WARNINGS ON HAIR DRYERS OR ANTI
TIPPING ON COOKING OR OTHER LIFE
THREATENING WARNINGS THAT HAVE
TO BE AVAILABLE. WE HAVE
PROVIDED A WARNING LABEL THAT IT
SHOULD BE PUT ON ALL COOKING.
LET'S LET'S GET REAL ABOUT
INDOOR AIR QUALITY. IF YOU COOK,
YOU NEED TO VENTILATE ELECTRIC
OR GAS. THAT'S TEN TIMES THE
POLLUTANTS IS COOKING. PM 2.5 IS
66% OF THE POLLUTANTS THAT
DWARFS ALL THE POLLUTANTS
TOGETHER. AND PM 2.5 IS WHAT
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS SAY. WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON THAT IS TEN
TIMES MORE WHEN YOU'RE COOKING
ANYTHING, REGARDLESS. SO IF YOU
MOVE PEOPLE FROM GAS TO ELECTRIC
AND YOU STILL DON'T EDUCATE THEM
ON THE NEEDS FOR VENTILATION YOU
HAVE CAUSED SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
RISKS. I WOULD ASSUME THE
SCIENTISTS WOULD ALL AGREE TO
THIS. CERTAINLY, PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS DO. THAT'S WHAT WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON AND THAT'S WHAT
WE PROPOSE A SOLUTION IN
GOVERNMENT AND BUSINESS TOGETHER
TO HAVE A CREDIBLE, TRUSTED
MESSAGE THAT CONSUMERS CAN
BELIEVE IN AND RELY ON. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
JUST FOR CLARIFICATION, I
BELIEVE THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
DO CLARIFY. THAT THE WARNING
LABEL WOULD CLOSELY ALIGN WITH
THE EXISTING STATE GUIDANCE FROM
CARB, CORRECT. AND OSHA, SO THAT
IS JUST I RESPOND TO THAT. NO,
NO, I'M SORRY, I'M JUST
CLARIFYING THE AMENDMENTS, BUT
WAS CLOSELY ALIGNED. IT DOESN'T
ALIGN. WELL, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE'VE HEARD YOUR
TESTIMONY. SO WE APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU. ABSOLUTELY ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL BRING FORWARD
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL, PLEASE. YEAH. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS.
SILVIO FERRARI, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. ISRAEL
SALAS WITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
GAS COMPANY IN OPPOSITION AS
WELL. GOOD MORNING, LIZZIE
KUTSUNA HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN PROPANE GAS ASSOCIATION
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
WHO'D LIKE TO OPPOSE THE BILL,
PLEASE COME FORWARD SEEING NONE.
SO WE'LL TAKE IT BACK FOR
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS
. NO QUESTIONS, NO COMMENTS.
YES, SENATOR DALLI, EXCUSE ME.
THANK YOU. SO, IN REGARDS TO THE
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY, FIRST,
NUMBER ONE, I GOT A COUPLE
QUESTIONS. NUMBER ONE, I BELIEVE
OUR BUILDING CODES IN CALIFORNIA
REQUIRE VENTILATION, UNDER WHEN
YOU CONSTRUCT A HOME. SO I THINK
THAT'S NUMBER ONE. NUMBER TWO,
WE HAVE PROP 65, WHICH REQUIRES
AS A MANUFACTURER OF SOMETHING
THAT'S TO CAUSE CANCER OR, OR
HEALTH EFFECTS HAS TO BE POSTED
ON THE APPLIANCE. SO CAN I GET
AN ANSWER TO THOSE TWO THINGS.
WE ALREADY HAVE THAT. SO YOUR
BILL IS NARROWING DOWN TO JUST
GAS. BUT IT SHOULD BE LABELED
RIGHT NOW AS CANCER CAUSING IF
UNDER PROP 65. WELL PROP 65 IS A
VERY SHORT WARNING AND IT
DOESN'T GO AS FAR TO DIRECT THE
CONSUMER TO ALSO VENTILATE. AND,
I'M GOING TO BE 62 YEARS OLD
THIS MONTH AND THROUGH THE
COURSE OF THIS BILL, I LEARNED
THAT VENTILATION IS REQUIRED.
ALSO WHEN I'M USING THE OVEN. I
HAVE NEVER DONE THAT. I'VE
ALWAYS USED IT WHEN I USE THE
STOVE TOP AND THINGS ARE SMOKING
AND I USE MY VENTILATION, BUT
I'VE NEVER USED IT WHEN I'M
COOKING A LASAGNA IN THE OVEN.
NOW I DO, BECAUSE I'VE LEARNED A
LOT FROM RUNNING THIS BILL. SO
THIS IS WHAT WE WANT TO DO. WE
WANT TO INFORM CONSUMERS OF
INFORMATION AND THE TOXIC GASES
THAT GAS STOVES DO EMIT, AND
WHAT THEY CAN DO TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
SO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THEN, IS
AN ELECTRIC STOVE DOESN'T EMIT
ANY OF THOSE ONLY GAS. I'D BE
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT REQUIRING
YOU'RE NOT REQUIRING. SO THE
DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS AND IT
MATTERS TO THE CONSUMER BECAUSE
WE'RE MISLEADING PEOPLE JUST
WITH THE OPPOSITION. WAS TALKING
ABOUT, LOOK, I'M IN BUSINESS AND
EVERYTHING THAT A LOT OF THE
STUFF THAT WE USE IN BUSINESS IS
PROP 65 LABELED, AND NOBODY
READS THEM ANYMORE BECAUSE
EVERYTHING'S PROP 65 LABELED.
AND THERE ARE SOME OF THOSE
THINGS THAT YOU REALLY NEED TO
FOCUS IN ON. SO THE REASON I ASK
THESE QUESTIONS IS BECAUSE I
THINK IT MATTERS THAT WE'RE
TELLING THE PUBLIC, I MEAN,
THERE'S A THERE'S A CAMPAIGN
AGAINST GAS RIGHT NOW. I
PERSONALLY DON'T BUY INTO IT,
BUT I DO DID READ SOME
BACKGROUND ON YOUR BILL AND
COOKING, WHICH IS WHAT THE
OPPOSITION BROUGHT UP WITH
CAUSES, CARCINOGENS AS WELL. SO
I THINK WE NEED TO BE HONEST
WITH THE PUBLIC. WE'RE JUST
GOING TO PUT A LABEL ON THERE
BECAUSE THERE'S PEOPLE IN THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT DON'T LIKE GAS.
BUT LET'S BE HONEST, DOES
COOKING CAUSE CARCINOGENIC? YES.
WHETHER IT'S ELECTRIC OR GAS.
AND SHOULD WE HAVE VENTILATION?
YES. THEN THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD
BE TALKING ABOUT. SHOULD WE PUT
IT ON ALL APPLIANCES? YES. NOT
JUST NARROW ONE OUT, BECAUSE
THAT'S THE NARRATIVE OF THE DAY.
THAT'S THE POINT I'M TRYING TO
BRING. ABSOLUTELY. AND IF I
COULD HAVE OUR CALPIRG EXPERT
RESPOND TO YOU, THAT'D BE GREAT.
AND I AND I WOULD LIKE THE
OPPOSITION TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AS WELL.
SURE SO TO ANSWER A COUPLE OF
THOSE QUESTIONS ON PROP 65. SO
PROP 65 IS JUST WARNINGS FOR
THINGS THAT ARE CAUSING CANCER,
REPRODUCTIVE HARM. SO THAT'S THE
BENZENE FORMALDEHYDE. IT DOES
NOT WARN PEOPLE ABOUT THE
NITROGEN DIOXIDE CARBON MONOXIDE
, THINGS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH RESPIRATORY ILLNESS AND
INCREASED RISK OF ASTHMA
SYMPTOMS. SO THAT'S WHY WE WANT
TO HAVE THE ADDITIONAL WARNINGS
ON THIS LABEL. IN ADDITION OF
COURSE, TO THE RECOMMEND NATIONS
TO VENTILATE WHEN IT COMES TO
THE EMISSIONS FROM COOKING. SO
IT'S TRUE THAT PARTICULATE
MATTER CAN BE RELEASED WHEN
YOU'RE COOKING REGARDLESS OF THE
FUEL THAT YOU USE. IF YOU'RE,
YOU KNOW, BASICALLY BURNING
SOMETHING, COOKING WITH HOT OIL
THAT CAN CREATE POLLUTION. WHAT
THIS LABEL IS FOCUSED ON IS THE
POLLUTION THAT COMES FROM THE
APPLIANCE ITSELF. SO JUST BY
TURNING ON THE OVEN, TURNING ON
THE STOVE, REGARDLESS OF WHAT
YOU'RE COOKING, THERE ARE
POLLUTANTS THAT COME FROM THAT
FLAME BECAUSE IT'S THE PRODUCT
ITSELF. THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO
FOCUS ON WARNING PEOPLE ABOUT.
WE THINK COOKING IS JUST IS
SEPARATE. YOU KNOW, THERE COULD
BE A SEPARATE WARNINGS ABOUT
COOKING. I THINK THAT NEEDS TO
BE A LITTLE BIT MORE RESEARCH
INTO THE IMPACTS OF PARTICULATE
MATTER FROM COOKING. THERE'S A
LOT ON THE RESEARCH DONE AROUND
THE GAS STOVE ITSELF. POLLUTANT
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON
ON THE PRODUCT ITSELF. I THINK
THOSE WERE THE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. I'D LIKE THE OPPOSITION TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY AS WELL, IF
I MAY, MADAM CHAIR. SURE, SURE.
THANK YOU, THERE'S A LOT OF, SO,
FIRST OF ALL, ON THE LABELING,
IF YOU HAVE A POINT OF SALE
LABEL, IF YOU GO TO HOME DEPOT
TO BUY A COOKING AND AS A
CONSUMER, ALL YOU SEE IS A LABEL
THAT GAS COOKING NEEDS TO BE
VENTED, THEN WHAT ARE YOU GOING
TO THINK? OH, I CAN BUY
ELECTRIC. I DON'T NEED TO VENT.
THAT'S WHERE TEN TIMES THE
POLLUTANTS ARE. THAT'S
MISLEADING THE CONSUMER AND
ACTUALLY HAVING AN ADVERSE
IMPACT TO PEOPLE'S HEALTH.
SECONDLY, I'M JUST BAFFLED BY
THE SAYING THAT THERE'S NO
STUDIES ON PM 2.5. THAT'S ALL
YOU HEAR ABOUT FROM PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS. WE HAD A TASK
FORCE THAT WAS CHAIRED BY PERG
AND AM AT THE CONSUMER PRODUCT
SAFETY COMMISSION, SPECIFICALLY
ON THIS, WE INVITED CARB TO
PARTICIPATE, WHICH THEY DID.
HEALTH CANADA, THE CPSC AND EPA,
ALL FOUR OF THEM SAID PM 2.5 IS
WHAT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
IMPACT. AND WHEN YOU COOK 66% OF
THE POLLUTANTS, 66% OF THE
POLLUTANTS ARE PM 2.5. WHEN YOU
COOK, THE REST OF THE POLLUTANTS
ALL DWARF THAT WE NEED TO BE
TALKING ABOUT PM 2.5 AND ALL
COOKING AND VENTILATION. THAT'S
WHAT THEY ALL SAY. THAT'S WHAT
OUR WARNING LABEL DOES. IT'S
HONEST, IT'S CREDIBLE, IT'S
BELIEVABLE, AND IT WILL IMPROVE
PEOPLE'S HEALTH. ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE WE'RE THROWING PEOPLE
UNDER THE BUS AND DOING A
DISSERVICE FOR THOSE PEOPLE THAT
COOK WITH ELECTRIC. THANK YOU.
THAT NEED THESE HEALTH
INFORMATION AS WELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SO WE'VE HEARD FROM
BOTH, JUST TO BE EQUITABLE HERE.
SO SENATOR DOLLY, ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS? OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
WOULD I'LL VOTE NO LIKE ALWAYS.
OKAY. WE HEARD IT HERE FIRST.
ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS, I
PERSONALLY JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING FORWARD THIS
BILL. I'LL LET YOU CLOSE FIRST,
BUT I WILL I'LL JUST SAY WHAT I
HAVE TO SAY AND THEN WE'LL LET
YOU CLOSE HOW ABOUT THAT?
BECAUSE I'M IN THE MIDDLE OF
THAT. YES, THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD, HAVING A,
YOU KNOW, WORKED ON INDOOR AIR
QUALITY ISSUES, AND KNOWING THAT
, YOU KNOW, OUTSIDE IN MANY OF
OUR DISTRICTS IS HORRIBLE. BUT
THEN YOU GO INSIDE, IT COULD BE
EVEN MORE HORRIBLE. AND WHAT
YOU'RE DOING IS PROVIDING A
WARNING WITH STATE GUIDELINES,
YOU KNOW, THROUGH CARB AND THE
OTHER OFFICE. AND SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING. I WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED
AS A COAUTHOR AS WELL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, PLEASE CLOSE ASSEMBLY.
WELL, AS YOU AS YOU SAID, THIS
IS A LABEL TO INFORM CONSUMERS
OF, THE POSSIBILITY OF HAVING
THESE TOXIC GASES IN THEIR HOME
AND HOW THEY CAN MITIGATE THAT
BY VENTILATING. I EVEN OPENED A
DOOR AS WELL TO ENSURE I'VE GOT
GREAT VENTILATION GOING. AND
IT'S TO PROTECT OUR FAMILIES AND
OUR CHILDREN. SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION? I SEE ONE BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR AGAIN. ALL
RIGHT. GREAT. A MOTION BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. AND THIS IS A
Dð PASS TO SENATE. DO PASS AS
AMENDED. EXCUSE ME, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATORS GONZALEZ, I
GONZALEZ, I DALI. NO. DALI. NO.
HURTADO LAYERED. LAYERED. I
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NGUYEN
SKINNER. THANK YOU. OKAY, WE
HAVE NEXT UP IS NUMBER SIX, FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX. NÓ ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN. THIS IS PERFECT
TIMING. SENATOR DALI, I CHAIR
DALI. I HAVE I HAVE A BILL YOU
CAN VOTE YES ON RIGHT HERE, I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS BILL. I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENT TO
SHORTEN THE SUNSET DATE TO
JANUARY 1ST, 2032. IN 2018, I
AUTHORED LEGISLATION TO PROVIDE
A CEQA EXEMPTION FOR INFILL
HOUSING PROJECTS WITHIN
UNINCORPORATED AREAS OF A COUNTY
TO BE A TOOL TO HELP ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING CRISIS. PRIOR TO THIS,
THERE WAS ALREADY AN EXEMPTION
FOR INFILL PROJECTS, BUT ONLY IN
CITIES. THIS EXEMPTION OR THE
EXEMPTION IN MY PREVIOUS BILL,
WHICH SUNSETS NEXT YEAR
INCORPORATED THE SAME NARROW
CONDITIONS AS THE EXEMPTION IN
CITIES, AS WELL AS PROVIDED
FURTHER LIMITATIONS TO PREVENT
SPRAWL. ACCORDING TO STATE
CLEARINGHOUSE DATA, THE
EXEMPTION HAS BEEN USED FOR NINE
PROJECTS RANGING FROM 10 TO 98
UNITS, FOR A TOTAL OF 378 UNITS.
AS CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO FACE
A HOUSING CRISIS ACROSS THE
STATE IN ALL COMMUNITIES, AB
2199 WOULD EXTEND THIS EXISTING
TOOL TO PROMOTE INFILL HOUSING
PROJECTS IN OUR COUNTIES WITHOUT
ADVERSELY IMPACTING THE
ENVIRONMENT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND WITH ME
TODAY ARE TWO WITNESSES CHRIS
LEE, ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA, AND JOHN
KENNEDY ON BEHALF OF RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. MR. CHAIR, READY
WHEN YOU ARE. YES THANK YOU SIR.
ALL RIGHT. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
DALI AND MEMBERS, CHRIS LEE HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA, WE'RE AN
ASSOCIATION OF 15 OF THE LARGEST
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA. I THINK
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT COUNTIES, A
LOT OF THE TIMES WE FOCUS ON
THINGS LIKE COUNTYWIDE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES OR PUBLIC
SAFETY. BUT WHAT'S SOMETIMES
FORGOTTEN IS THAT COUNTIES HAVE
ALL THE SAME OBLIGATIONS AS
CITIES TO PLAN FOR THEIR HOUSING
NEEDS. IN THE UNINCORPORATE
AREAS, WE'VE GOT MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
UNINCORPORATED AREAS. IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY, OVER A MILLION
PEOPLE RESIDE IN THE
UNINCORPORATED AREA. SO IT'S
WORTH THINKING ABOUT HOW WE
ACCOMMODATE THOSE HOUSING NEEDS,
HOW WE MEET STATE GOALS RELATED
TO REDUCING VMT IS PROTECTING
AGRICULTURAL LAND AND NATURAL
RESOURCES. WE THOUGHT IT WAS
VERY IMPORTANT THAT COUNTIES
HAVE THE SAME SORT OF REGULATED
INCENTIVE THAT HAS EXISTED IN
CITIES FOR DECADES TO ENCOURAGE
INFILL DEVELOPMENT, TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT MORE CERTAINTY THAT
THESE PROJECTS, WHICH ARE
ENVIRONMENTALLY BENEFICIAL IN
NUMEROUS WAYS, AS WELL AS MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE LIVING
CLOSE TO RESOURCES LIKE SCHOOLS,
PARKS, SHOPPING ARE EXPEDITED.
AND SO WE'RE VERY PLEASED TODAY
TO BE THE SPONSOR OF AB 2199.
DON'T WANT TO REITERATE ANYTHING
THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS
ALREADY COVERED, BUT THERE ARE A
LOT OF EXCEPTIONS HERE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE AREN'T
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. REYES
THIS YEAR, WE ADDED A PROTECTION
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S NO
IMPACT TO TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES. AND DESPITE ALL OF
THESE EXCEPTIONS, WE'VE STILL
SEEN THE EXEMPTION USED TO
EXPEDITE SOME VERY GREAT
PROJECTS IN COUNTIES LARGE AND
SMALL FROM AROUND THE STATE. SO
HERE TODAY, TO ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. GOOD MORNING, JOHN
KENNEDY WITH CRC. WE REPRESENT
40 OF THE STATE'S SMALLEST
COUNTIES. AND I'LL BE BRIEF
BECAUSE CHRIS SUMMED EVERYTHING
UP PRETTY WELL, IT'S A SIMPLE
BILL. IT'S AN IMPORTANT TOOL FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. WE SUPPORT IT
BECAUSE IT'S A TOOL IN OUR
TOOLBOX TO BRING HOUSING TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE MANY
UNINCORPORATED AREAS, EITHER
LOCATED AS ISLANDS WITHIN CITIES
OR IN SUBDIVISIONS THAT HAVE
CHOSEN NEVER TO INCORPORATE AND
BECOME A CITY, THIS BILL ALLOWS
US TO CONTINUE USING THIS
EXEMPTION FOR HOUSING PROJECTS
IN THOSE AREAS, LAKE COUNTY WAS
ONE OF THOSE SMALLER RURAL
JURISDICTIONS WHO USED THIS
EXEMPTION TO BUILD 69 UNITS ON
AN INFILL SITE. SO IT HAS BEEN
USED. WE HOPE IT'S USED MORE
FREQUENTLY IN THE FUTURE. AND
STRONGLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON
THIS BILL TODAY. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ME TO. GOOD MORNING. MARK
STIVERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT
SPECIFICALLY FOR ITS IMPACT ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. LAUREN
DE VALENCIA, REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, MATT
KLOPFENSTEIN, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS GREAT BILL,
SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS. ANYONE WISHING
TO ASK A QUESTION, I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR AND YOU MAY CLOSE. MR.
BERMAN, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS GOOD
BIPARTISAN BILL. THANK YOU. THIS
WAS GOING TO HOUSING. HOUSING AS
AMENDED. CALL THE ROLL, PLEASE.
SENATORS GONZALEZ DALY. AYE.
DALLY. AYE. HURTADO LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE MENGIBAR. HENGERVAR.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NGUYEN. AYE.
SKINNER THANK YOU. WE'LL LEAVE
THAT BILL ON. CALL TO MEMBERS TO
ADD ON. OKAY. WE'LL TAKE UP AB
2522 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CURIEL.
HOW ARE YOU? GOOD, GOOD. GOOD
MORNING. LET ME KNOW WHEN READY.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I TOO HAVE A
BIPARTISAN BILL THAT I HOPE
COULD GARNER YOUR SUPPORT. I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT AB 2522, WHICH
WILL RAISE THE COMPENSATION
LIMIT FOR SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
BOARD MEMBERS TO $200 A DAY AT
MOST $2,000 A MONTH, AND
AUTHORIZE A YEARLY COMPENSATION
INCREASE NOT TO EXCEED 5% OR DUE
TO INFLATION, 10. AIR DISTRICT
BOARD MEMBERS ARE DEDICATED
PUBLIC SERVANTS ENTRUSTED WITH
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY AND
ESTABLISHING EFFECTIVE CLEAN AIR
PROGRAMS. DESPITE THEIR
IMPORTANCE TO OUR ENVIRONMENT,
THE COMPENSATION LIMIT FOR BOARD
MEMBERS WAS LAST AMENDED IN
1987. THAT'S 37 YEARS AGO. AT
THIS TIME, THE COMPENSATION
LIMIT WAS SET AT $100 PER DAY,
NOT TO EXCEED 1000 PER MONTH.
OVER TIME, THIS FIGURE HAS
DIMINISHED WITH INFLATION AND
DOES NOT REFLECT THE PUBLIC
SERVICE THESE BOARD MEMBERS
PROVIDE. THIS BILL WOULD
INCREASE THIS FIGURES TO $200 A
DAY AT MOST 2000 A MONTH, AND
PROVIDE THE BOARD MEMBERS AND
PROVIDE THAT THE BOARD MAY
INCREASE COMPENSATION UP TO 5%
OR 10% DUE TO INFLATION.
MOREOVER, WE PLAN TO AMEND AB
2522 AND SENATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE TO SIMILARLY INCREASE
COMPENSATION LIMITS FOR THE BAY
AREA, SACRAMENTO, SAN DIEGO AND
UNIFIED AIR DISTRICTS. THE SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT HAS BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH OTHER PARTNERS
AND OTHER AQMD SAYS THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION. IT HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS AND
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND HERE TO
TESTIFY IS SENIOR PUBLIC AFFAIRS
MANAGER FOR THE SOUTH COAST AQMD
PHILIP KREPP. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS PHILIP CRABB
AND I REPRESENT THE SOUTH COAST
AQMD. WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB 2522 AND SERVE AS THE
BILL'S SPONSOR. THIS BILL WOULD
INCREASE OUTDATED COMPENSATION
LIMITS FOR BOARD MEMBERS OF
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS AND
AUTHORIZE FUTURE INCREASES BASED
ON CONSUMER PRICE INDEX. THE
CURRENT BILL LANGUAGE FOCUSES ON
SOUTH COAST. AS MENTIONED, BUT
WE'LL BE EXPANDING IT TO COVER
OTHER VARIOUS AIR DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. IN
GENERAL, COMPENSATION LIMITS FOR
AIR DISTRICT BOARD MEMBERS HAVE
NOT INCREASED SINCE THE 1980S.
IT WAS SET LAST FOR EXAMPLE,
SOUTH COAST AQMD IN 1987 AT $100
PER DAY AND BASED ON INFLATION,
AN EQUIVALENT AMOUNT IN 2024
WOULD BE OVER $270 PER DAY. THIS
BILL WOULD DOUBLE CURRENT LIMITS
TO MODERNIZE COMPENSATION TO BE
MORE COMPARABLE TO THE LEVEL SET
NEARLY 40 YEARS AGO. AIR
DISTRICT BOARD MEMBERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE
DEDICATED IN THEIR EFFORTS TO
CLEAN THE AIR AND PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. THEY
ARE PUBLIC SERVANTS WHO OFTEN
TRAVEL LONG DISTANCES AND
PERFORM AN IMPORTANT PUBLIC
SERVICE WITH NOMINAL
COMPENSATION. THE OUTDATED PER
DIEM LIMITS PRESENT CHALLENGES
FOR AIR DISTRICT BOARD MEMBERS,
WHO OFTEN HAVE OTHER ESSENTIAL
DUTIES TO PERFORM AS LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS OR PRIVATE
CITIZENS WHO WITH EXISTING
CAREERS THAT MUST PROVIDE THEIR
PRIMARY FINANCIAL SUPPORT. AB
2522 ALSO CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY
TO OPPORTUNITY TO ENHANCE EQUITY
IN ENVIRONMENTAL GOVERNANCE,
IMPROVE FINANCIAL INCENTIVES
COULD ATTRACT A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE ARRAY OF
CANDIDATES, INCLUDING THOSE FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. THE BILL ENHANCES
LOCAL CONTROL BY EMPOWERING
LOCAL AGENCIES TO APPROPRIATELY
UPDATE PER DIEM RATES GOING
FORWARD, WITHOUT IMPACTING THE
STATE BUDGET. THIS IS IN LINE
WITH SB 329 DODD, SIGNED INTO
LAW IN 2023 THAT MORE THAN
TRIPLED COMPENSATION FOR LIMITS
FOR CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT? SEEING NONE. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE, WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS.
SENATOR MENGIBAR. THERE YOU GO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR. VICE
CHAIR. ASSEMBLYMEMBER, I KNOW
YOU KNOW, WE IT HASN'T BEEN
INCREASED IN A LONG TIME. MY
ONLY CONCERN IS, IS TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS. I HOPE NOW
IT'S THERE'S MORE INCENTIVE TO
REALLY ADDRESS THE AIR QUALITY
AND AIR POLLUTION IN THE AREA. I
HAVE A LOT OF CRITICISMS OF SK,
C, AQMD, BECAUSE I REPRESENT
AREAS THAT HAVE AN IMMENSE
AMOUNT OF TERRIBLE AIR
POLLUTION, WHERE MAYBE NOW, WITH
THIS INCREASE WILL ACTUALLY BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
ADDITIONALLY, I DON'T THINK THIS
IS FULLY GETTING AT THE EQUITY
ISSUE, I, I THINK IF WE REALLY
WANT TO ADDRESS EQUITY, WE
REALLY SHOULD HAVE PEOPLE ON
THIS BOARD WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCES. MORE FROM THE
COMMUNITY, MAYBE FOR ANOTHER
BILL. I AM GOING TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL, BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S
MEETING THE MARK. OKAY. THANK
YOU, SENATOR DALI. FIRST OFF, I
LIKE THE BILL. BUT THERE'S ONE
THING I AM CONCERNED ABOUT ON
THE BILL, AND THAT IS THE
ABILITY FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
RAISE THEIR OWN RATE IN THE
FUTURE, AND IT WOULD BE, I
GUESS, KIND OF HARD FOR ME TO
GET AROUND THAT PART BECAUSE, IT
NEEDS TO BE PUT OUT INTO THE
PUBLIC THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
DOING IT SOMEHOW THAT NEEDS I
KNOW, I KNOW, THEY HAVE TO VOTE
ON IT, BUT LIKE, IT CAN'T GET ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. I MEAN,
THOSE ARE THE THINGS I'M
THINKING ABOUT. LIKE NOT JUST
ALLOWING IT TO BE PUT ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND YOU'RE
GOING TO RAISE IT WHATEVER THE
MAXIMUM OF CPI IS, EVERY TIME IT
COMES AROUND. BECAUSE OVER TIME,
WITH INFLATION, THESE THIS COULD
GO FROM $2,000, TO 5000 REALLY
QUICK. IF WE HAVE INFLATION LIKE
WE'VE SEEN IN THE PAST. SO I
JUST WAS KIND OF YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THAT MAYBE ABOUT MAYBE
PUTTING MAKING SURE THAT IT HAS
TO BE AGENDA ITEM, MAYBE NOT
JUST PUT ON CONSENT AND JUST
PASS THROUGH EVERY TIME THERE'S
AN ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO DO IT.
SURE. YES. PLEASE PHILIP, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO SPEAK ON THE PROCESS
OF EQUITY? SURE, ABSOLUTELY, NO.
AS YOU MENTIONED, SENATOR, IT
WILL GO THROUGH A PUBLIC
PROCESS. IT IS NOT SPECIFIED IN
THE BILL. BUT OF COURSE, THE
BOARD WOULD HAVE TO TAKE Dð A
PUBLIC HEARING. SO WE'RE HAPPY
TO HAVE MORE DISCUSSIONS IN
TERMS OF BEING MAYBE OUTLINING
SOMETHING, MORE SPECIFICS ON THE
LOGISTICS OF HOW THIS WOULD
OCCUR. JUST TO FOLLOW UP, I KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO ADD OTHER AIR
DISTRICTS TO IT BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS NOT JUST A
PROBLEM IN YOUR AREA. IT'S A
PROBLEM THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WHERE YOU'RE HAVING, YOU KNOW,
LOW COMPENSATION. BUT BUT THESE
MEMBERS ARE MEMBERS OF BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS AND CITY COUNCILS TO
START WITH. RIGHT. THAT THEN
THEY'RE APPOINTED TO THEIR
DISTRICTS, SOME, AND THEN THERE
ARE I BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
ALSO PUBLIC MEMBERS AS WELL.
CORRECT. THERE ARE WELL, THERE
ARE MEMBERS THAT ARE APPOINTED
BY THE GOVERNOR, BY THE SENATE,
BY THE ASSEMBLY. THEN WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM LIKE THE
DIFFERENT FOUR COUNTY
SUPERVISORS, ALSO MEMBER CITIES
FROM WESTERN CITIES AND EASTERN
CITIES. THAT'S JUST IN SOUTH
COAST. THERE'S SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT PROCESSES FOR
DIFFERENT AIR DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. SO SOME OF
THEM THAT ARE LIKE CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS OR, OR, BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, THEY'RE
COMPENSATED. BUT THE AT LARGE
MEMBERS THAT ARE APPOINTED BY
THE GOVERNOR AND THE SENATE ARE
NOT COMPENSATED. ONLY THE $100.
CORRECT. IT'S EQUAL ACROSS ALL
MEMBERS. THEY ALL RECEIVE THE
$100 PER DAY PER DIEM, THE
CURRENT ONE SET BACK IN 1987.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
AND I WILL SORT OF ALIGN WITH
WHAT SENATOR MENGIBAR MENTIONED,
ALTHOUGH I DO SUPPORT THIS BILL,
I DO BELIEVE THAT THIS WORK IS
SO VALUABLE FOR, AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AND ONE OF
THE LARGEST AIR QUALITY
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE AND
NATION, BUT TO, YOU KNOW, AS
SOMEONE WHO'S, AUTHORED A BILL
ON EJ SEATS AND STILL FEELING
THE REPERCUSSIONS FROM FROM THAT
BILL, QUITE HONESTLY, FIVE YEARS
LATER, I DO WANT TO SEE THOSE
VOICES. AND EQUITY SHOULD BE AT
THE FOREFRONT OF THIS TYPE OF
WORK. SO I KNOW YOU BELIEVE IN
THAT, AND I ASSURE YOU THAT I
KNOW THAT AND FEEL ASSURED THAT
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK IN THAT
IN THAT VEIN. SO, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMENTS. I TOO, REPRESENT AN
AREA THAT HAS BEEN IMPACTED BY
AIR QUALITY, RELATED TO RAILWAYS
AND MANUFACTURE OTHERS AND
HOUSING BEING BUILT AROUND
COMMUNITIES THAT TRADITIONALLY
HAVE NOT HAD HOUSING IN THE
PAST. AND BECAUSE OF THE IMPACT
OF HOW THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
AND UNINCORPORATED AREAS HAVE
PRODUCED HOUSING AROUND CERTAIN
AREAS, AIR QUALITY IS CERTAINLY
OF IMPORTANCE TO ME. WHAT I HAVE
SEEN IN CERTAIN APPOINTMENTS IS
THAT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO GET
WHEN ON THE CONVERSATIONS AROUND
EQUITY, IT IS DIFFICULT TO GET
EVERYDAY PEOPLE WHO HAVE JOBS,
WHO HAVE EVERYDAY LIVES TO BE
INVOLVED ON BOARDS SUCH AS THIS,
WHEN THE COMPENSATION IS SO LOW.
AND SO THAT'S ALSO A CHALLENGE,
RIGHT? AND SO HOW DO WE GET
FOLKS THAT LIVE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TO BE A PART OF THE
CONVERSATION AND ALSO BE ABLE TO
MAKE A LIVING. AND SO THIS MAY
REQUIRE ATTENDING BOARD MEETINGS
AND NOT GOING TO WORK AND
MISSING OUT ON OTHER TYPES OF
PAY. SO THEN HOW DO WE ACTUALLY
MAKE IT EQUITABLE FOR FOLKS TO
WANT TO PARTICIPATE IN
GOVERNMENT AND BOARDS ON
CONVERSATIONS THAT IMPACTS THEIR
DISTRICTS RELATED TO AIR
QUALITY? SO I HOPE THAT THIS IS
A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO
GET THOSE VOICES ON THESE BOARDS
AND HAVE FOLKS BE A PART OF THE
CONVERSATION. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THIS
HAS BEEN MOVED BY I DON'T KNOW
WHO CAN. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATORS. OKAY. SENATOR MENGIBAR
MOVES THE BILL AND THIS IS A Dð
PASS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE AB 22522. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATORS GONZALEZ AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. DALLI HI. NO. NOT
VOTING. I'M SORRY. HURTADO.
HURTADO AYE. LAIRD I LAIRD. AYE.
MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR. AYE. NGUYEN
SKINNER. OKAY. WE'LL LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ALL RIGHT. THAT
WRAPS UP OUR FILE HERE, WE'LL GO
DOWN THE LINE. I KNOW WE'VE GOT
A ONE OTHER MEMBER THAT'S JOINED
US. IF ANY OTHER MEMBERS CAN
PLEASE JOIN US. WE ARE NOW,
PULLING THE CALL, OR WE NEED A
MOTION ON LIFTING THE CALLS
HERE. BUT FIRST WE'LL START WITH
FILE ITEM ONE, AB 457. WE DO
NEED A MOTION. WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM. AND THAT IS, AS AMENDED,
RIGHT? YES. CORRECT. AND I WOULD
MOVE THAT BILL AS AMENDED.
PERFECT THANK YOU. SENATOR
LAIRD. AB 457, A MOTION BY
SENATOR LAIRD, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED,
AS AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. SENATOR GONZALEZ I
GONZALEZ I DALLY I DALLY I
HURTADO HURTADO I LAIRD LAIRD I
MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I NGUYEN I
NGUYEN I SKINNER. I60 OKAY 6 TO
0 ON CALL. OKAY. GREAT FILE ITEM
TWO AGAIN HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR. THAT'S AB627. SO WE'LL
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM THREE AB
SIX. I'M SORRY. FILE ITEM FOUR
AB 805 ARAMBULA. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SENATORS HURTADO HURTADO I
NGUYEN I NGUYEN I SKINNER 6060
OKAY SIX ZERO. WILL LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL AND FILE ITEM FIVE
AB 990 GRAYSON, THAT IS Dð
PASSED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 4
TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS HURTADO. HURTADO I
NGUYEN NGUYEN I SKINNER. OKAY.
SIX ZERO. THE BILL IS STILL ON
CALL FILE ITEM SIX AB 2199.
SENATOR I'M SORRY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN DO PASS IS AMENDED
TO SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0 WITH THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ I HURTADO I
HURTADO I SKINNER I SKINNER I.
7070 THE BILL IS OUT. WE'LL MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM SEVEN AB 2503.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 3
TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR DALLI. SENATOR HURTADO
HURTADO I NGUYEN SKINNER.
APOLOGIES I COULDN'T HEAR WHAT
YOU KNOW. THAT FILE ITEM SEVEN
AB 2503 ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE. BY
OKAY SKINNER, I. AND THAT IS,
THE BILL FIVE 5 TO 0. THE BILL
IS OUT. FILE ITEM EIGHT AB 2513
PELLERIN DO PASS AS AMENDED. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING. VOTING NO.
SENATORS HURTADO. HURTADO I
NGUYEN NØ NGUYEN. NO. SKINNER.
SKINNER I. 5 TO 2. THE BILL IS
OUT. FILE ITEM NINE AB 2522.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARRILLO DO PASS
TO SENATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 4
TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR STALEY NGUYEN SKINNER A
SKINNER. I 5 TO 0. THE BILL IS
OUT. OKAY WE'LL MOVE AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE BACK TO THE TOP.
ACTUALLY, WE'LL START WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR FOLKS WHO
ARE NOT HERE, CONSENT CALENDAR
AGAIN HAS FILE ITEMS THREE, TEN,
11, 12, 13, 14 AND 15. THAT'S
SEVEN ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR, AND WE'LL START AT THE
TOP, PLEASE. OKAY. SENATORS
HURTADO HURTADO, I WIN, I WIN, I
SKINNER, I SKINNER, I. SEVEN
ZERO ADOPTED SEVEN ZERO. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL WE'LL START AGAIN
WITH FILE ITEM ONE AB 457
AGUIAR-CURRY. OKAY. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 0 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
SKINNER. AYE SKINNER. AYE. OKAY.
SEVEN ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM THREE AB 637. JACKSON
I'M SORRY. FILE ITEM FOUR AB 805
ARAMBULA. THE MOTION IS TO PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 6
TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. OKAY. SEVEN ZERO. THE BILL
IS OUT. FILE ITEM 5AB9 90.
GRAYSON. DO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 0, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
RIGHT. SEVEN ZERO. THE BILL IS
OUT. FILE ITEM SIX AB. DID WE
ALREADY DID THAT FILE ITEM. IT'S
BEEN A LONG DAY. MY APOLOGIES
EVERYBODY. FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
2577. OKAY. SEVEN IS OUT. WE'RE
GOOD TO GO. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR
SKINNER, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US. AND THAT IS IT.
WE'VE ADJOURNED TODAY. THANK YOU
EVERYBODY.